youth unemployment is the most
challenging issue for European country
certainly it is challenging social
cohesion and indeed political stability
so we need to have a strategy to deal
with that I know that the focus within
countries such as my own Island has been
on balancing our budgets for people call
austerity and but their needs in tandem
to a fiscal responsibility strategy
there needs to be a growth and jobs
strategy and there are a number of
prospects to stimulate jobs we need to
have a much more robust European
Investment Bank freed of the
bureaucratic difficulties to invest in
job creation in the short term we need
to look at the structural funds within
the European Union to ensure that they
are redistributed with a focus on
creating jobs for young people and in
particular for upscaling people into the
available job markets there are a range
of potential issues that need to be
addressed as a matter of urgency but the
first thing obviously is the recognition
that the issue of youth unemployment is
and of itself a top priority for
European leaders and not simply to have
an exclusive look our focus on fiscal
stability